the rescue effort in New Bern has been
going all night long or curfew just went
into effect there lasting through 7:00
a.m. tomorrow Kris Van Cleave is a New
Bern with the latest on that part of the
story Kris good morning do we have you
yes we have you hello good morning Gail
good to see you this morning we are
inside New Bern Fire Station 1 this is
where FEMA search-and-rescue teams have
been working out of crews from Texas and
Massachusetts as well as the New Bern
Fire Department have been out in boats
like this most of the night we know that
there have been hundreds of rescues the
last update we had was about 150 people
still waiting to be rescued
ominous updates being put out by the
city of New Bern on Facebook things like
don't go into your attic unless you can
cut ventilation in the roof but we are
coming for you crews here are getting
set you can see they've got boats ready
to go we know just seven or eight blocks
from here the water is 6 feet deep or
more this is a very treacherous
situation we can tell you the roads
getting here overnight Gail were very
treacherous we were dodging trees coming
down huge sinkholes opening up in front
of us it was a very dangerous Drive and
that has nothing to do with the fact we
also ran into standing water that got
very deep very quickly city of New Bern
was bracing for up to 13 feet of storm
storm surge we know they've gotten a lot
of water and the rain has been
relentless so has the wind so these are
the search and rescue crews these folks
are from Massachusetts there's a Texas
crew that just deployed a few minutes
ago they're gonna go out and they're
gonna try to get to everyone we hear
people are in cars people are in homes
trying to get out trying to get the dry
land and that is the race right now is
to get to all of them in time Gail and
Chris I'll take it the police lieutenant
earlier this morning telling us at 911
is operating and they are waiting for
calls for those who need help